Europa glaubt dass Mittelalter hinter
sich gelassen zu haben keine
Religionskriege mehr kein Gewalt im
Namen keine Gewalt im Namen der Religion
keine Unterdrückung der Frauen und
Minderheiten im Namen der Religion aber
mein ehrt sich das Mittelalter kommt
zurück nach Europa mit der Einwanderung
der Islam erlebt gerade sein eigenes
Mittelalter er weigert sich durch einen
Prozess Aufklärung zu gehen er weigert
sich Frauenrechte anzuerkennen er
weigert sich Religionskritik anzunehmen
und zu akzeptieren und sich damit
auseinanderzusetzen und das Ergebnis
davon sind kaputte Wirtschaften in der
islamischen Welt eine verheerende
Menschenrechtslage vor allem auch
Frauenrechte in der islamischen Welt
Bürgerkriege und Religionskriege
zwischen Sunniten und Schweden und all
diese Phänomene wandern jetzt und kommen
nach Europa und beschäftigen Europa und
werden Europa in den nächsten
Jahrzehnten beschäftigen
Terrorismus
Jugendgewalt in migrantenviertel
religiöses Moppen Mobbing an Schulen und
geklärt Kriminalität das ist nur die
Spitze des Eisberges und es wird noch
schlimmer und die Politik bleibt und
tätig und auch die Medien da erkenne ich
auch eine Diskrepanz zwischen dem was
passiert und dem was wirklich berichtet
wird die Politik und die Medien machen
sich teilweise zu Komplizen das
Islamismus in Deutschland weil sie nicht
kritisch genug über dieses Thema
sprechen
dazu mehr in meinem aktuellen Buch Islam
eine kritische Geschichte dass ich
morgen in Berlin vorstelle sind unsere
ZuschauerInnen Zuschauer damit alle
eingeladen werden
vielleicht ein aber wir wollen mal bei
diesem ganzen Thema bleiben und ich habe
gerade eben als ich sie vorgestellt habe
gesagt sie sind hier mit Polizeischutz
die stehen hier bei uns vor der
Studiotür erklären Sie uns einmal wie
konnte es dazu dass sie so leben müssen
weil das Mittelalter nach Europa auch
gekommen ist früher weiß ganz normal
dass jeder Mensch Jesus kritisieren
konnte oder die Bibel jetzt wenn
irgendjemanden den Koran oder Mohammed
kritisiert dann lebt er gefährlich dann
lebt er unter Polizei Schutz Mitten und
Europa im 21 Jahrhundert das ist für
mich ein Skandal das ist ein Angriff auf
meine Männchen würde und auf meine würde
alles Schriftsteller dass ich mehr als
sieben Personen Schütze brauche und
gepanzerten Fahrzeug und eine Schuss
sicherereste brauche um
meine Meinung um ein Buch über den Islam
vorzustellen das ist für mich ein
Skandal aber
die Demokratie lebt immer noch ich weiß
nicht wie lange noch und ich darf nach
wie vor auch in so einer Sendung meine
Thesen vorstellen aber in den meisten
Medien nicht mehr
sie bekommen Morddrohungen mehrfach in
der Woche fast jeden Tag was steht da
drin was wird ihnen da vorgeworfen es
wird mir vorgeworfen es wird mir
vorgeworfen dass ich vom Westen bezahlt
werde um den Islam schlecht zu reden um
den Propheten zu diskreditieren es wird
mir vorgeworfen dass ich ein Ungläubiger
bin ich gehöre geköpft ich gehöre
getötet
und eigentlich der Westen bezahlt
mittlerweile die Islam verbinde die hier
Salon für gemacht werden die Anhänger
von Erdogan werden von der Politik und
von den politischen Stiftungen hofiert
nicht ich im ich werde langsam aus dem
Diskurs verbannt weil ich den Islam
kritisiere ein elementares Menschenrecht
Religionskritik wie wäre die Aufklärung
ohne Religionskritik das ist eigentlich
und vor allem im Buch tun sie ja nicht
nur das also sie loben Islam für so
viele Facetten sie blicken auch noch mal
historisch zurück auf die Blütezeiten
des Islams sie sagen auch der Politik
ganz klar Musliminnen und Muslime können
wir in Deutschland so nicht behandeln
also ich muss sie da einmal selber in
Schutz nehmen sie haben genau das was
sie auch fordern eine offene Debatte
nicht nur Argumente in die eine Richtung
lassen Sie uns einmal den Finger in die
Wunde legen was läuft schief erstens
richtig also es gibt viele Muslime die
in diesem Land leben die sind
friedlicher Menschen und sie sind auch
loyale Staatsbürger aber es gibt auch
Anhänger des politischen Islam die das
Mittelalter aus den islamische Länder
importieren all diese Phänomene die für
für Bürgerkriege dort sorgen werden
hierher gebracht und mit Steuergeldern
eigentlich finanziert auch an deutschen
Schulen die jungen Muslime an deutschen
Schulen lernen wie Erdogan zu denken wie
Islamisten zu denken sie lernen in
westlichen Schulen wie sie den Westen
hassen können das ist
mehr als Grundgesetz die meisten
Muslime die hier leben achten das
Grundgesetz aber es gibt eine große
Minderheit die sagt nein zuerst kommt
der Koran zuerst kommt die Sharia ihre
Loyalität gilt nicht dem Gemeinwesen
oder dem Rechtsstaat sondern der
muslimischen Oma der muslimischen
Gemeinschaft dem Imam
Chef und das ist natürlich gefährlich
und das ist deshalb dass die Phänomene
die wir sehen wie Jugend Gewalt das ist
nicht nur ein soziales Problem weil sie
arm sind oder weil sie arbeitslos sind
sondern weil sie auch von zu Hause aus
gegen den deutschen Staat und gegen
diese Gesellschaft angestachelt werden
und gehetzt werden sie betrachten ihre
deutschen Nachbarn alles Ungläubige weil
sie Schweinefleisch essen oder Alkohol
trinken oder Sex vor der er haben und
wie können Sie mit diesen Menschen als
Staatsbürger umgehen wie können Sie
diese sich mit diesen Menschen
anfreunden wenn Sie glauben Gott hat sie
und ich muss auch sie hassen so kann man
sich nicht integrieren und so lebt die
Frustration weiter und so kommt dieser
Gewalt die langsam gährt wir haben
gesagt wir wollen hier eine offene
Debatte führen gerade in diesem
Zusammenhang das erwähnen sie auch in
ihr in ihrem Buch ist ein ganz schnell
bei Kritik die Rede von Rassismus
deswegen kann man annehmen sind viele
vorsichtig geworden zu formulieren
Finger in die Wunde zu in die Debatte
hineinzugehen wie nimmst du das war so
da gibt es zwei Aspekte oder bzw es
kommt von zwei verschiedenen Strömungen
die eine Strömung ist dass wir eine
große Gruppe haben am legalistischen
Islamisten die zwar auch eine Minderheit
sind aber eine große die schon
anzugucken Krawatte tragen die in der
Wissenschaft sind in den Universitäten
und ich kann die Namen rechtliche nicht
sagen weil sonst würden wir verklagt
werden so ist es äh ich vermissten
benutzen das häufigsten Mittel um
Kritiker wie ihn und mich
einzuschüchtern das habe ich jahrelang
erlebt und diese wissen Wissenschaftler
diese Islamisten Anzug und Krawatte
schreiben dann Bücher über Hamed
abdissermatt stellen Ihnen als
islamophob da als rassistisch und
versuchen damit natürlich jede Kritik an
politischen Islam und dann
islamistischen Strukturen zu
delegitimieren und die zweite Strömung
ist von wem das auch ausgeht sind von
links grünen Politikern in Deutschland
am stärksten aber auch teilweise von ich
kann es auch von konservativen
Politikern z.B in Nordrhein-Westfalen
und jedenfalls diese Politiker haben
sich irgendwie indirekt auf die Seite
geschlagen von Islamisten weil sie in
ihrem Weltbild einfach das nicht sehen
wollen dass es Parallelgesellschaften
gibt das es Islamisten Anzügen gibt und
was ich beobachten kann als Journalistin
die sich jahrelang mit Islamismus
befasst ist definitiv das legalistischer
Islamismus wächst und zwar enorm seit
den 50er Jahren in Deutschland wachsen
islamistische Strukturen die sind nicht
kleiner geworden sondern sie sind größer
geworden und vor allem die die tolerant
geben die jetzt Gendern dieses gender
Sternchen benutzen die werden größer und
die Lobby ihren die Politik aber diese
parallel Entschuldigung diese
Parallelgesellschaften wo sind die in
der Hauptstadt in Berlin oder an anderen
Orten also
wollen sie wie wird das Experte machen
wir haben diese Parallelgesellschaften
überall in in Deutschland das ist nicht
nur Neukölln und Kreuzberg sondern auch
in anderen Stadtvierteln in Berlin ich
sehe das also ich werde fast in jedem
Stadtviertel angegriffen auf der Straße
auch wenn ich mit der Polizei
laufe ich kann mittlerweile in Beirut
oder in Dubai ohne Polizeischutz laufen
aber nicht in Berlin das ist unmöglich
so schlimm ist das Problem schon
geworden und diese Politiker die sind
nicht naiv sie wissen ganz genau was
passiert sie lesen auch meine Bücher und
sagen toll tolle Thesen ich glaube das
auch aber sie sind opportunistisch
erstens
sie haben wirtschaftliche Interessen mit
der Türkei und mit den Golfstaaten und
sie wollen sie nicht verärgern sie haben
auch Interessen mit
Islamverbänden in Deutschland weil sie
die Wähler mobilisieren CDU oder SPD
oder die Grünen zu wählen und man will
diese Wähler nicht verscheuchen und dann
manche haben Angst alles rassistisch
oder islamophob abgestempelt zu werden
und so kann man nicht ein Problem lösen
wenn man das Problem nicht einmal nennen
darf und wenn Menschen die das Problem
nennen sofort alles rechts ich bin alles
andere als rechte ich bin eigentlich mit
den Gedanken von Jean Paul satore
sozialisiert und intellektuell erwachsen
geworden aber sie zwingen mich immer an
den rechten Rand nur weil ich die den
Finger in die Wunde lege und sage wir
haben ein ernsthaftes Problem mit dem
Islam und mit der Migration und über
dieses Problem zu reden ist heißt nicht
Generalverdacht werden alle Muslime im
Gegenteil ich finde
Islamkritik heute zu Tage ist nicht nur
ein Menschenrecht sondern ein Menschen
Pflicht den der Islam hat ein Problem
und es liegt im Interesse der Muslime
selbst dass sie über dieses Problem
reden
ich kann gar nicht anfangen
ja als wir diese Randale haben und wir
haben versucht eine Debatte hier in
Deutschland zu führen die wir aber nicht
hinbekommen haben zu führen stattdessen
haben wir darüber geredet was wie wir
die Debatte nicht führen sollen und was
rassistisch ist und vor allem kam das
wieder von links grünen Politikern die
dann auch hier gefordert haben die die
Debatte über die Herkunft zu beenden wir
brauchen eine Debatte die Ideologie frei
ist natürlich ohne Vorteile und
Rassismus zu stören und das das Proteste
ist doch das links grüne Politiker ja
Menschen die herkommen hier
haftpflichten aus anderen Ländern vor
allem die Nahen Osten den Schutz bieten
wollen aber genau diese Menschen die
Leiden sind doch die Leidtragenden davon
denn die werden ja auch hier
retraumatisiert wenn in Deutschland
wieder rufen darf dann dann ist das ein
Retraumatisierung und das und dann
nehmen die Politiker die Menschen eben
nicht in Schutz und man darf nicht
vergessen wie rassistisch der politische
Islam ist
Herr Peters nehmen Sie das auch so wahr
haben sie Sorge vor einer Drohnen
Radikalisierung also ich frage mich vor
allem wann der Islam eigentlich falsch
abgebogen ist und ich ich muss eine
kleine Geschichte zu erzählen ich mich
meine Diplomarbeit tatsächlich natürlich
meine Eltern gewidmet als Sponsoren aber
dann Alkohol war es mir das war der
derjenige der die das Rechnen mit der
Null erfunden hat und und popularisiert
hat vielleicht hat das aus Indien
mitgebracht was weiß man nicht aber er
war eine also ein leuchtende Größe im 9
jahrhundert ähm 19 Jahrhundert und er
das war eine Zeit wo der Islam
unglaublich produktiv war wenn
hat gesagt die ähm und das war weit
fortschrittlichen Verhältnis zum zum
Christentum man hat gesagt
allah ist Gott also aller ist
allumfassend also ist auch das Studium
der Natur ist ein Studium Allahs also
muss das gottgefällig sein und dagegen
hat man bei uns irgendwelche
platonischen Ideen hochgehalten hat
gesagt die Naturforschung
wollen wir hier eigentlich nicht so
richtig und paar Jahre nach nine eleven
habe ich mich dann sehr stark mit mit
dem Koran und so auch auseinandergesetzt
und habe gemerkt dass es ein für eine
unglaubliche ein Fortschritt war in der
Antike im siebten Jahrhundert es ist
eine sehr tolerante Religion eigentlich
also ganz anders als man es heute kennt
aber was wir in in Europa halt hatten
ist das noch nicht mal die aufklären die
Aufklärung war ich immer eher das Ende
dieser geistigen Entwicklung die begann
mit den scholastikern die
Institutionen geschaffen haben also dass
das nicht der König war sondern das
Königtum und diese Entwicklung hatte
Islam
offensichtlich nicht mitgemacht jeder
Dorf Imam darf eine Fahrt war
aussprechen ohne ohne ohne
Funktionen oder ohne ohne Kontrolle und
was ich sie eigentlich gerne fragen
würde ist wo ist da eigentlich der Islam
oder wann ist der falsch abgebogen warum
hat er sich nicht weiterentwickelt warum
über solche Themen heute überhaupt ja
also zuerst man macht immer den Fehler
zu glauben dass der Islam an sich für
diese Entwicklung im Mittelalter
verantwortlich war für die Mathematik
und die Philosophie es war nicht der
Islam sondern die griechische
Philosophie die ins Arabische übersetzt
wurde sie hat eine Wissensrevolution
entgangen gesetzt es gab ein paar
tolerante Herrscher die eigentlich viele
von ihnen waren sogar homosexuell die
damals ja der regiert haben und sie
waren tolerant und und auch die
Vermischung von Völkern die Juden haben
eine Rolle gespielt die Christen die
Perser Alkoholismus war kein Araber
sondern ein Perser und so waren die
meisten Wissenschaftler und die meisten
Philosophen zu diesem Zeitpunkt wäre der
Islam für diese Entwicklung
verantwortlich gewesen dann hätte diese
Entwicklung Entdecker und Medina ähm
beginnen können nicht in Bagdad und
nicht in Cordoba wo ehemalige
Hochkulturen dafür verantwortlich waren
wann ist der ist die islamische Welt
abgebogen alles die islamik cancel
culture entstanden ist als die
religiösen Gelehrten gesagt haben
Philosophie ist haram ist nicht es
verboten alles sie bestimmt haben du
darfst den Koran nicht kritisieren
früher dürfen das schon das war schon ab
dem 12 Jahrhundert und da
geschah im 12 Jahrhundert in der
islamischen Welt was heute in Europa
passiert mit ganzer culture und mit
Identitätspolitik und mit Tribalismus 7
Mentalität die Rationalität war weg und
langsam kam Emotion kamen Emotionen und
kamen religiöse Identitäten und die
Religion bestimmte was geschieht und was
gesagt werden wird heute ist es wieder
Identität und Religion die bestimmen was
wir sagen und was wir nicht sagen soll
und Europa muss aufpassen und das ist
das womit ich gemeint habe dass das
Mittelalter langsam nach Europa
einwandert einmal noch
lösungsorientierte denken geben Sie uns
ein paar Hinweise darauf dass die
Politik was wir als Gesellschaft was
gefahren werden muss um dieser
Radikalisierung die sie in ihrem Buch
beschreiben Einhalt zu gebieten was
passieren muss damit das friedliche
Zusammenleben von denen wir alle Träume
möglich ist wir müssen mit Muslimen
umgehen erstmal alles Individuen alles
Bürgen und nicht alles eine Gruppe und
nicht als Kinder das sagen sie auch ja
wenn ich jetzt Islamkritik unterbinde
aus Rücksicht auf religiöse Gefühle dann
behandle ich Muslime wie Kinder nicht
wie erwachsene Menschen die kritikfähig
sind die auch auf Kritik mit Kritik
antworten können das ist das erste
zweitens die Politik muss aufhören diese
Islamverbände salon-projekt zu machen
mit Fördergeldern zu unterstützen sie
werden sowieso von der Türkei und von
den Golfstaaten gelenkt um hier
türkische und arabische Politik auf
deutschem Boden so machen das muss
beendet werden die Bildung muss sich
befreien von diesen Islam Unterricht und
islambildung die von den Islamverbänden
kontrolliert werden und endlich mal muss
die Politik und die Medien und die
Zivilgesellschaft für die Freiheit
einstehen
es tut mir manchmal leid dass ich
Menschen die in der Freiheit geboren
sind über die Freiheit unterrichten muss
das will ich gar nicht
er muss mich unterrichten über die
Freiheit ihr seid da geboren ich bin in
der Unfreiheit geboren in Ägypten musste
mich von mal von der politischen
Diktatur und von der religiösen Diktatur
befreien um hierher zu kommen um meiner
Meinung frei zu sagen und am Ende muss
ich dann unter Polizei Schutz stehen um
diese Meinung zu sagen das muss beendet
werden da mussten die Politiker die
Schulden uns die Antwort was ist schief
gelaufen sie müssen die Lösungen
präsentieren und Sie müssen das Kind
beim Namen nennen kein Mensch kann ein
Problem lösen ohne zuerst das Problem
klipp und klar zu benennen